[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces sujets sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon interprétation
dans la crise du coc vite 19
sans tomber dans la recherche du bouc
émissaire chara rené girard c'est toute
une chaîne décisionnelle médicales
administratives et politiques qui
responsables du fiasco
il est la conséquence d'une dérive qui
vient de loin et à laquelle le politique
a essayé sur fait tant bien que mal sans
y réussir vraiment
après la grippe asiatique de 1957 qui
fit cent mille morts en france et celle
de 1969 qui en fit 31000 et pour
lesquels il n'y eu aucun confinement ou
ont été confrontées à celles du strass
et du h1n1 or elles n'ont pas eu
l'impact redouté d'une pandémie que tous
les experts en prospective attendait du
coup nous avons que nous maîtrisions ce
type de risque et qu'il n'était pas
nécessaire de s'en protéger sérieusement
à l'opposé des mesures de précaution
prôné en son temps par la ministre
roselyne bachelot à laquelle les faits
donnent raison aujourd'hui notre
administration technocratique et un
pouvoir trop éloigné de la population
ont privilégié de retour sur
investissement plus rentable au plan
politique ou financier au détriment de
la santé publique de nos concitoyens il
n'a été tenu aucun compte les études
prospectives françaises et étrangères et
même des livre blanc de la défense
nationale il y en a eu 2 qui annonçait
comme risques majeurs une pandémie par
virus les décisions préconisé en 2012
par le secrétariat général de la défense
nationale
puis toute la chaîne sanitaire sur le
stock de masques comme la réduction
progressive en quinze ans le 15 pour
cent des lits dans les hôpitaux dont
entre parenthèses le problème des
urgences ou des infirmières n'était
qu'une partie émergée de l'iceberg en
sont une démonstration évidente parmi
d'autres d'un autre côté nous avons
pêché par présomption en n'anticipant
pas la suite dès que la pandémie a été
avérée en asie qu'il soit issu du marché
vivant de hauranne ou du laboratoire p4
fournies par la france
nous avons eu les premières informations
sur le type de virus et sa capacité de
contagion par les chinois et par l' oms
dès le début janvier
alors que certains pays européens et
asiatiques s'équiper en urgence pour
piloter la crise
nous avons attendu trop tard en
présumant nos capacités techniques
par suite du blocage bureaucratique
d'une bonne partie de la chaîne
décisionnelle française par comparaison
l'allemagne qui avait fait en 2018
un exercice en grandeur réelle annoncé
la mise au point d'un test dans la
deuxième partie du janvier compléter son
niveau de masques et renforcer sa
capacité de 20000 disponible en
réanimation par la réquisition et
l'équipement de salles de sport prévue
chacune pour cent les pluies alors quand
on voit ça on peut le comparer avec la
france qui en pleine crise d'
insuffisance de lits et d'appareils
respiratoires a mis dix jours pour
déployer un hôpital militaire de
campagne de 30 lits avant d'organiser le
transfert de plus de 600 malades vers
d'autres hôpitaux publics sélectionnés
dans toute la france et vers les pays
limitrophes
alors que l' oms recommandait le port du
masque par les populations
la parole publique a longtemps menti sur
sa nécessité pour ne pas avouer la
triste absence du stock requis dans la
bataille tardive pour en acquérir
on a bien vu tout est loin d'être
idyllique si la république tchèque a
carrément détourner un stock en route
pour l'italie
n'oublions pas les américains récupérant
dans un aéroport
le stock acheté pour les français et
comment ils l'ont fait dans tous les cas
de figure c'est toujours la même chose
parce qu'on a vu ça aussi avec la grande
distribution française quand il s'agit
d'avoir des masques le problème est
simple
certains pays les masques cash c'est à
dire immédiatement quand ils les
reçoivent d'autres payent à 30 jours
d'autres payent à 90 jours vous
connaissez la france c'est un des pays
où on paie le plus mal et le plus tard
voilà le résultat
alors que la corée du sud et singapour
avait évité le confinement par les
gestes barrières les tests le traçage
des malades et la surveillance des gens
exposés
nous avons dû bien entendu recourir au
confinement quasi totale quand les pays
du nord de l'europe se sont tous mis en
confinement partiel alors le combat au
quotidien contre le coc vide 19 qui
mobilise l'état et le monde de la santé
va continuer à être prioritaires jusqu'à
la fin de la pandémie et nous devons
tous y contribuer sans hésiter les
querelles d'experts aux liens parfois
avéré avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
sur les traitements applicable montre
combien la france médical est divisée en
chapelles dogmatique
n'oubliez pas pro garder ce qui vient de
se passer aux états unis avec l' annonce
du président tram sur les médicaments
qu'il prend suite aux conseils de ses
propres médecins
espérons que tout cela n'aura pas un
impact sur le nombre de décès par
rapport aux cas identifiés car nos
résultats à l'heure actuelle sont
inquiétants en dépit du dévouement
formidable il faut bien le dire du
personnel soignant dans le pays du
principe de précaution
la décision de confinement s'imposait
compte-tenu du manque de matériel
permettant d'autres solutions mais en
freinant l'hécatombe
on pénalise l'économie plus elle dure
sous une forme ou sous une autre
et plus la récession sera forte
nous avons connu ces derniers temps des
crises économiques
en 2008 c'était une crise bancaire dans
laquelle la spéculation des banques
pouvaient les amener à la faillite et
ruminer les épargnants en 2018 on les
imagine jaune il s'agissait d'un
mouvement social de revendications de la
petite bourgeoisie la classe moyenne
basse qui travaille dur pour gagner peu
et se sentaient paupérisée oubliés des
élites en 2019 c'était la conséquence
d'un fort mouvement social syndical
d'opposition à une réforme intéressante
mais mal préparés expliqué mais celle ci
est beaucoup plus profond les
conséquences du confinement vont avoir
un impact direct sur l'économie et des
conséquences sociales majeures même si
lé télétravail a permis conserver un
volume d'activité la baisse de la
production et le ralentissement des
échanges est énorme et il va pénaliser
durablement notre pays nous aurons cette
année d'après mes calculs en prenant les
chiffres des différents systèmes
économiques et des conseillers
économiques français et étrangers nous
aurons une récession proche de 10% soit
deux fois plus forte que nos voisins
allemands qui sont les grands gagnants
européens de cette crise le gouvernement
essaie de répondre au mieux aux
problèmes de survie des entreprises
toutes tailles et des citoyennes tous
ordres en passant d'un état libéral à
une économie administrée et malgré tous
ses efforts
cela va s'accompagner inévitablement de
faillites d'entreprises de toutes
tailles avec les problèmes d'emploi qui
en découlent
dans un environnement qui va être
inflationnistes pour le pouvoir d'achat
des français
notre déficit étant beaucoup plus
important et l'imposition fiscale à un
niveau particulièrement élevé pour un
pays européen
il va falloir faire des économies en
dépit des largesses actuelle l'état ne
pourra plus être l'état providence que
nous avons connu le temps de retrouver
notre niveau actuel il va falloir faire
des choix courageux qui seront forcément
mal vécue et la pression sociale va être
terrible de surcroît la valorisation de
nos entreprises étant réduite du fait de
la crise il va falloir empêcher les
grands prédateurs internationaux de
venir faire leur marché à bas prix car
la tentation est forte
nous savions depuis 20 ans qu'il
existait une coupure entre le sud le
nord et l'est de l'europe
la crise l'a malheureusement confirmée
avec l'abandon du sud à son triste sort
qui était déjà dans la logique vu pour
les migrants il n'est pas étonnant que
les pays du nord qui ont moins confiné
et vont repartir plus vite n'ai pas
voulu financer des corona bond pour
aider les pays du sud qui vont mettre
plusieurs années à récupérer
devant l'incapacité de coordonner une
solidarité européenne qui reste à
l'heure la présidente de la commission
s'est vu obligé de s'excuser envers
l'italie houran aura été le cimetière de
certaines espérances et montrer que le
concept d'europe des nations chira de
gaulle avait encore de l'avenir
le président de la république semble
vouloir en tirer les conséquences
politiques au niveau de la souveraineté
nationale et dans ce cadre la france
l'espagne et l'italie ne doivent elles
pas étudier et proposer rapidement une
autre vision et un autre format européen
qui réponde mieux aux attentes de nos
concitoyens également relancé cette
union de la méditerranée dont les pays
du nord ne veulent pas n'oubliez pas que
si je passe aujourd'hui avec les 500
milliards décidés par la chancelière
avec le président de la
blick c'est un moyen de calmer la fureur
de ceux du sud qui comprennent bien que
dans cette affaire ce sont les grands
perdants
plus les êtres humains se regroupent
plus les risques d'épidémies sont élevés
quand la circulation au dialecte
important grâce aux transports eh ben on
rentre dans les pandémies et cette crise
est loin d'être la pire de notre
histoire
et pourtant c'est la première avec un
confinement
parce que l'homme moderne refuse la mort
en vertu d'un principe idéalisée de
précaution par contre le côté anxiogène
de sa médiatisation outrancière et
orienter la rend difficile à vivre et
surtout empêche d'anticiper
rationnellement ses conséquences
économiques et sociales
tout le monde a oublié que l'incertitude
est une composante de la condition
humaine
d'un côté il faut remettre au plus vite
la france au travail et de l'autre il
faut tout faire pour éliminer la
pandémie la solution est au mieux mais
elle n'est pas facile à évaluer et à
mettre en oeuvre
ne serait ce que parce que la différence
de situation entre les régions est
importante
l'un discipline mortifère de certains
est très forte et le gaullisme sans
limite d'autres citoyens qui parlent de
leurs droits en oubliant
systématiquement leurs devoirs est
préoccupante
parallèlement à la relance progressive
de l'économie
il y a obligation d'éradiquer le virus
dans la population
puis de reconstruire un système de santé
capable de faire face à la prochaine
pandémie qui est inévitable ceux qui
vont gagner au niveau mondial sont ceux
qui ne se seront pas arrêtés car ils
avaient un niveau de préparation élevé
pour ce type de crise comme la corée du
sud singapour taïwan ou le japon la
chine qui a mieux géré la fin de sa
crise que son début va profiter de
l'amélioration relative de sa situation
pour marquer des points en europe et
ailleurs les états unis d'amérique en
grosse difficulté vous
leur système de santé trop sélectif et
l'absence de protection sociale le tout
se joignant à l'arrêt de la production
de gaz et pétrole de schiste ou du moins
le ralentissement de la production de
pétrole et de gaz de schiste suite à la
chute du prix du baril de pétrole vont
être obligés de réagir en trouvant des
boucs émissaires
la russie s'est repliée sur elle-même
pour régler son problème près de nous
l'allemagne qui a privilégié le
confinement partiel en s'appuyant sur
des tests de dépistage et valence et je
le disais un énorme plan de relance
économique devrait prendre une avance
significative sur les pays de l'europe
du sud
enfin n'oublions pas que si les banques
centrales et les états ont mis en place
des mesures de sauvetage de l'économie
loin de toute éthique des opérateurs
financiers de tous les coins du monde
ont gagné des fortunes sur le malheur
des peuples en spéculant à la baisse sur
les marchés
nous étions en train de jouer aux
apprentis sorciers en pensant que le
progrès faisait de nous des hommes dieu
et que les technocrates avait les clés
du monde de demain les conséquences de
la crise oblige à repenser nos modèles
la finance sans contrôle
elle progresse en limite ne sauveront
pas la planète
pas plus que le recours à la
décroissance écologistes dont on voit
aussi les limites aujourd'hui la nature
chères à spinoza re s'est chargé de nous
rappeler qu'elle est notre véritable
condition humaine la prise de conscience
de notre perte progressive de liberté
territoriale par la dépendance de
produits et de services
venus d'ailleurs montre notre fragilité
espérons que tous ceux qui ont un rôle
dans la recherche et l'action politique
économique ou social analyse froidement
la situation dans tous les domaines en
regardant ce qui a marché et ce qui n'a
pas marché ils auront à définir les
contours d'une nouvelle politique plus
humaine plus sociale plus territoriale
et moins financière pour sortir des
modèles remarquable conceptuellement
mais inadapté à la réalité dont on nous
abreuve ces dernières années il faut
tourner le dos à ce que finkielkraut
appelle la bêtise de l'intelligence pour
retrouver les bases la sagesse populaire
s'appuyant sur la souveraineté tout
n'est pas régulé par l'économie de
marché il va falloir apprendre à gérer
dans le temps
la discontinuité qui crée l'angoissent
mais aussi les opportunités
après une période du bri où la planète
nous paraissait petit hainaut pouvoir
sans limite
la crise va ramener tout le monde à une
réalité incontournable
nous étions dans une fuite en avant
privilégiant le paraître au détriment de
l'être sans tomber dans une paranoïa
écologique ou collabo logique qui est
l'autre face des excès de la finance ou
du progrès il est évident que la crise
économique et ses conséquences sociales
oblige à nous remettre en cause la
découverte du télétravail l'intérêt de
consommer des produits locaux
disponibles au lieu d'aller les chercher
au bout du monde
le besoin de solidarité qui s'opposent
aux incivilités et au communautarisme
vont faire évoluer une population qui a
découvert qu'elle était mortel la
démonstration que les gens sont capables
de travailler chez eux comme dans
l'entreprise aura des conséquences sur
les organisations les niveaux de
responsabilité et l'utilisation des
moyens de transport déjà vécu avec les
militaires
l'altruisme et des soignants à tous les
niveaux va obliger à redéfinir l'échelle
des valeurs de référence dans notre
société et c'est tant mieux
cela devrait redonner du poids au
collectif et à l'éthique par rapport à
l'individualisme et à l'incivisme
souhaitons le
car alors cette crise dramatique aura
été bénéfique en permettant de changer
le cap d'un bateau qui faisait route
depuis un demi siècle verra monde
illusoire qui confondait l'instant et
l'avenir en ne vivant que dans un
éternel présent à bientôt
[Musique]